uncle Joey here you bad [ __ ]
Monday November 19th nothing but love
for you mother [ __ ] savages it's a
beautiful day to be alive people always
ask me Joey how do you start a Monday
morning you gotta write your goals for
the day that's number one number two you
gotta get something to get you going
nothing better than the legs up ones a
lot of love you understand me right
there you're ready to [ __ ] do when
you show them the [ __ ] turntable for
right there you ready to do a number two
back but not us we got our mind
everywhere this gives you two options
whether you gonna be a sack of [ __ ] all
day or you're gonna rot and stab
[ __ ] and take back what's yours
you understand me right here this is
what Monday mornings are for
[Music]
that's number one you got a new do
number two cuz you can't walk on one leg
I'm saying unless you want a roller
skate with a [ __ ] helmet on whatever
the [ __ ] you wanna do and we ain't
[ __ ] around this morning we got the
big mule always the best thing after
girl right there this is it right there
from [ __ ] my main man over there
urban trees 8 a.m. they're already open
doing jumping jacks what the [ __ ] have
you done with your like this swingin
weed [ __ ] anyway another quick
one for the wing I'm saying
[Music]
it's like listen like that have a great
day I love you
Happy Thanksgiving the church it's on
its way [ __ ] don't worry about
nothing I got you
[Laughter]